hey guys welcome back to the evident
caitlyn podcast i'm absent that's the
intro it's a nice standard thing that we
can stick with primo are weed ditching
you're super clever and rose i don't
know because this is the second time
we're recording this podcast yes we
recorded this entire podcast it was
great it was great except the audio
sounded like robots if you've been on
our twitch streams you might experience
this time to time we have audio issues
it was that for an hour-long podcast but
kind of guess what this time it's gonna
be even better yeah because you know
what we know all of the good parts of
the last one the boring part yeah we're
not gonna like try to we're not gonna
try to like recreate it bit by bit
this is gonna be fresh there's gonna be
new fresh and new and I'm not frustrated
in any way Evan definitely hasn't been
working to troubleshoot this for the
past five hours I think that that we've
talked about this before on the podcast
like doing things again is like my my
most angering frustrating thing biggest
pet peeve repeating things but guess
what this is gonna be this is gonna be
like no matter what this is gonna be the
take because even if the recording on
this computer the primary recorder fails
us again I won't be upset because I have
a backup for the audio what if the video
dies so Caitlin that has your only
podcast so I have backup video is
recording over there too it's
interesting because a what's new little
behind the scenes update is over the
past week I've been working on the
podcast and streaming setup I've put in
probably 12 hours Oh more more than 1200
going crazy I think
hours but it's been more than a week
it's been like three weeks it's been a
lot of time yeah
put into what we do behind the scenes on
here but I think I'm finally approaching
a place that I feel really good about
each time something fails I learn more
it's the make fail make fail make fail
but it's sometimes when you fail too
much in a row it just is saddening but
you know let's move on let's move on to
two other updates other what news before
we move on to the main subject which is
going to be interviewing each other yeah
so the original intent for this podcast
the first time we that we recorded it
was to kind of go back and forth do some
fun interviews who thought the last time
we recorded this the entire podcast was
taken out by the very first question
because it was such a good question I
asked Caitlyn the best question and
really it's about her editing because
that's something that she does a lot
behind the scenes and I thought it'd be
really interesting to do a deep dive
into some of how that's evolved over
time so that's gonna be the main topic
of this entire podcast but first what's
new Kalyan tell us about flute all Pluto
a flute update so we hung flute all in
our room cuz it seemed like fitting to
have like a relaxing sleepy cloudy and
it was really cute it's so cute I wish I
had gotten a photo of him before we took
him down but so me and you but we're in
there and as I say we were reading Jesus
he might have been sleeping day dreaming
about [ __ ] she was dreaming she was
like twitching like a little kitten like
puppy puppy dreams I took a video so he
doesn't show up to see ten I went to
birthday she's almost 10 almost 10 years
old she's an old maid okay so y'all
reading anyways we're reading and flu
tolls hung in the corner we just hung
him like the day before and I hear this
like and I'm like what is that maybe I
imagined it maybe is the house making
noises and then it goes the second time
I was louder and joob like kind of
startles awake and I'm like that's that
flute I'll and then
just keep hearing these like groans and
grunts coming from little and so I was
like avid who told Browdy
so Evan being taller than I am was able
to like peek into him more and the
structural additions that I made in the
moment of removals where I just like
snipped parts out just to fit more stuff
in there it probably wasn't the best
thing to do on the very top of it
because like that's where everything
hangs from anyway is the hot glue that I
use detached and it was just hanging by
the LED strip we're just holding but the
LED strip was slowly getting pulled out
getting like yanked out which isn't the
best but I think just like you know
there are so wires intact nice need to
make some little loops on the inside I
can just reach in have some loops it's
no big deal but flu tile has suffered
but flu tile shall rise again Oh another
good flute will update when we say okay
flu tool like Google the tiny one the
Google hub mini or something it answers
- okay flute oh and I love it so we can
instead address the flute 'l instead of
the google which is just like it was
completely unintended yeah i came up
with the name flute Oh on the spot when
we were yeah right then and it just
works so good
we can ask flute 'el to like check the
weather for us or play play songs or
something it's just it's good so so
we've been getting some questions about
how flute was doing if we have hung
flute all and we're flute all is doing
well pretty much and flute shall rise
again but we're really enjoying we're
talking about this is the DIY versity
iCloud lamp oh yeah these people may not
see the video we probably should've said
that in the beginning yeah the first
time we probably did right in the first
one it would improve
we also wanted to give an update on
other past projects the fence that we
installed a lot of people commented that
we should probably seal it so that the
wood doesn't turn gray which we have
done yes
interestingly another comment people had
was that we put the boards too close
together and they don't have enough room
to breathe
but you know that's done so well I think
fairs I think that with the boards being
too close together since we added four
screws I think that's gonna stay
together yeah and it's not like the much
wait so I guess like there's only one
way to find out if they're gonna fail
and it's to live here forever and just
always check up on them yeah so there's
that I think that in general one thing
that we talked about in the last podcast
I'm just gonna be referring back to the
last podcast for any transition that I
need just like poco pull from that hat
a lot of our projects we haven't used
like in air quotes like best practices
for securing wood together like having a
bigger hole having that wiggle room
having screws but like held in by like a
fastener that allows for movement
we've just been group gluing everything
together and screwing everything
together and so far I mean we've gone
through more than a year of cycling for
a lot of our projects and they've held
up well so I'm just not fine I mean not
to say that you should follow all of our
woodwork like follow people that are
more professional than we are that but
like I also think that it can be pretty
forgiving and like worst case scenario
something like needs a little fixing a
little fixing
yeah something like bends a little bit
or whatever excuse for another project
you fix it later yeah or I just make
something else and you know I think
don't let it be - is it too intimidating
if you feel like you can only make a
table that has like you know Fox foxtail
joints and or like you know Japanese
joinery like super fancy stuff then you
not gonna make anything yeah so just
like pockets one other story that I
wanted to tell just because it was is
really fascinating when it happened to
me when I was carrying supplies back
from painting the fence back inside I
was wearing my headlamp because yeah we
were painting at night which is
something that we do and my headlamp I
don't know if it was like the specific
angle my headlamp was shining at or like
the focus beam or whatever but I saw all
these like glowing gems in on the in the
grass as I walk past them and I'm like
what what's glowing in the grass so I
just like I'm fascinated immediately
because it's very evident
they're quite bright and there were tons
of them there were like 20 clusters of
these like two bright gems in the grass
so you know I just kind of like get a
little bit closer to get a little bit
closer get a little bit closer and then
I realized they're the eyes of spiders
and there's like 20 spiders clustered in
our front yard and I don't know why a
patch yeah it was like a five-foot
circular patch and there were 20 fairly
large spiders not that large adult
spiders they were like babies they
weren't like they weren't like small
they were like sizable 0.75 inches there
were adults fighters it's not like like
there's like a hatch of I tiny spiders
they're like full spiders and I just was
like what and I'll at first I was like
whoa and I kind of backed up but I was
like that's so cool I should have just
gotten Caitlyn right um was telling me
about it on our way home from dinner and
so we were like oh let's go check the
patch and see if they're still there it
was the same night like later on in the
evening and I think I might have been
the next day was the next day everything
blurs together and but we got our phone
lights and we were like looking around
the patch for the spider spider patch
and we couldn't find it so we don't know
if it was just like if they migrated
those so crazy though it's like the
the light coming from their eyes was
much bigger than their eyes like I was
when I looked at them they glowed I
could see the facets they were like tiny
little diamonds looking back at me and
it was actually really pretty I feel
like my good sorry good sorry moving on
to the main topic the plan was just to
ask each other questions like you said
but let me ask the question that I wrote
down because as you guys I feel like I
did the transition better last night I'm
trying not to let it get to me so so
yeah this was gonna be a like.we Q&A
each other kind of thing and then
haven't started with this one question
and it lasted the whole time so now is
this gonna be about this question what's
your question baby so how has your
editing style evolved since you started
has it become easier or harder more fun
and I think that the the we've kind of
talked about one aspect of how our
content has changed so just to give
people like a little background on that
just in case you haven't watched some of
our previous podcast where or listened
to depending on how you consume the
podcast we kind of talked about it in
we've changed and we've changed too I
believe where we talked about how we've
evolved as a channel but I think that
from the con point a Content point of
view we started with just DIY content
and then we moved to more follow along
with us type content and now I don't
really know exactly what we're doing but
we're just having fun making stuff but
from an editing point of view I think
that there's been different points and
yes and last time because we can just
now that we've decided how many stages
there are because we've already talked
about it for 40 minutes now we can this
easily define the forest aging process
and I shall go into details of each
along
with tips it's like it's like after
dinner we're just like post-post curry
sleepy yeah and post curry giggles okay
um you know you know it's funny
when we mentioned pizza giggles in our
last video the grass wall art yeah a lot
of pizza Google's really resonated with
a lot of people a lot of people related
to pizza giggles Wow Pizza giggles our
thing I guess yeah yes so that was just
you okay so for the editing when we
first started the channel the editing
was like we kind of set it up in a very
safe way where we looked at what other
maker channels were doing we figured a
way to put our own spin on it but we we
did it in a way that was very easy to
accomplish our goals because we like
took out any unknowns so for these
tutorials before we started filming
anything we would completely script out
the entire voiceover and not only that
also have like exactly what shot to get
for every line of the voice-over and so
everything was predetermined we just
like would go down the list check off
the list the videos for like five
minutes long they're super short and and
I think that one benefit of doing it
that way is going into the video you
know you're gonna get everything that
you need yeah to edit the video and also
we were doing projects that were a
little bit more known yeah the most part
now some weed through totally through
wild cards in there like the self
watering planter we didn't know about
that or not
but like the first few were very known
and so we could kind of plan out how it
would go um and I think that made a lot
of sense for us starting because like it
was it made the filming itself more
time-efficient mhm
which was good because we were working
the time and so we could like I could
spend more time planning I would like
playing videos on my lunch break and
like all this stuff that way in nights
and weekends I could like wrap up the
plan and then we would we would film and
Evan would do more of like the project
planning whereas I was doing the video
planning and I think interestingly
that's one of the reasons that like I
started editing the videos because I
actually had a little bit more
experience on the software side of
things like I knew how the software
worked I never used premiere before yeah
our first video because I'd like put
together a little vacation highlights or
a little like we'll take one second
every day and I'll do like yearly like
videos where I pulled all of those one
seconds together and I'd like to make a
little compilation video which just is
so cute looking back but Caitlin did
have a little bit more experience with
the Adobe products and like graphic
design and and all of that and also I
don't know why I thought because like
premiere is so different and different
we didn't really utilize that if you
feel like now like at this point now you
are using a little bit more of the
graphical capabilities and stuff like
that and like all the layering you do
now so much layering so many effects but
but back in the beginning it wasn't much
of that but also I think that for me I
just like have a very much like good
enough attitude at times or like like
sometimes I'll go deep all like spend a
lot of time and really go deep like with
this podcast stuff but like the
streaming like the streaming podcast set
up like the technology side of things
but for at other times I'm just like
done and I just want to be done with it
and Kalyn will like make sure that it's
really good and for videos that are
gonna be up forever I think that she was
a much better choice because you don't
want to just like say like that's good
enough so so I think you were a hundred
percent the best choice for further
editor
I was not fast though
very slow in the beginning because they
were so much shorter in the beginning
one you are learning a lot and two I
think the thing that took the longest
amount of time is Kailen spent so much
time searching for the exact right song
because each video was basically defined
by that song back then
yeah well that's that's and so of the
phase one characteristics one I think
would be it was all planned out in
voiceover 2 was the song determined
every mm-hmm I would since so so much
time finding the perfect song cuz like
with the video that short it would
usually just be one song played behind
the entire video and I would cut
everything perfectly precisely to the
beats of the music and like if we had to
take away footage or add footage I would
have to redo the entire edit after that
because it would like to throw things
off so much because I had it time so
perfectly even not just like cut to the
beats but even like if there's a slow
part in the song I would pair that with
like a slower more chill part of the
video and so if I added something else
in before that it would push everything
and I'd have to get good at like
chopping the songs up and like cutting a
piece of the song or repeating a piece
of the song in order to make it work but
that was so tedious I don't take me so
long I just felt so bad whenever like we
thought of something that we needed to
add and it shifted everything it was
like no or even like when we first
started working with sponsors because we
were still kind of in that period or
that style of editing and if the sponsor
required to change that to change the
timing in any way it messed up
everything oh it was the worst another
interesting thing about timing is like
in order to edit I needed to have the
voice-over as well because I had to you
know I
whatever Clips corresponding to the
voice-over I needed to be the same
length as the voice-over and this and
that so I would record the whole
voiceover myself hmm and then I would
have Evan come in and like re-record
half the lines that way it was like
alternating between us
and at this point the video was already
edited so all the timing was determined
and all of the words were kind of
determined because I couldn't really
change the words because it changed the
timing and also since Caitlyn speaks
faster than I do and I take more natural
pauses because words are hard like my
brain is like running so fast ahead I
sometimes need to like rewind backwards
to the words I want to say so that I can
say them properly because it's really
not for me to talk really fast
anyways so I'd come in to record my
lines and I had such a hard time saying
words as fast as Caitlyn did and saying
the right words because we speak
differently with different words
structures and stuff like that
so that was like the hardest part for me
recording cuz like it would be like too
much pressure if I was in there because
also like if Kalyn likes and they come
on in and record these like five lines
the expectation for me is that it go
really fast my cadets record it in a few
like one or two minutes and then Kalyan
would just be able to hang out and then
she could get back to editing but
sometimes it take me so long and as I
messed up my words would get more
difficult to pronounce and I'd get more
frustrated which would make me try to
rush which would mess up my words just a
vicious cycle so that eventually we just
learned that Kalyan does has to leave so
I don't feel the time pressures that I
can require private lives better yes
even though we live in a very small
house if I am talking I can hear you
anywhere in the house Kalyan can hear me
pretty much so it's just like a very
small mental thing yeah yeah but it is
interesting like even then we still
because that sounds so not there's
anything wrong with that this it's like
a very common formula but it is so
formulaic that style of doing videos but
also not a bad thing it a lot easier to
start and especially for tutorials it's
like a method that works really really
was a lot less intimidating what we're
doing now but I do think it's
interesting even then we tried to like
work in
jokes into the voice-over yeah I felt
like we had to pre play at our jokes
funny like accidentally yeah not that it
always was funny but we try and we still
would end up capturing like accidental
bloopers and we include the audio would
be bad we did talk to the camera for the
intro and outro
yeah the audio was terrible yeah like
our audio that the cost of our audio
gear right now is prohibitive then yeah
because back then we didn't I think that
we had enough confidence to feel like we
could make it but we didn't have enough
confidence to spend that much money so
I'm stuff yeah and also we would have
bought the wrong things that was a big
part of it it was like we didn't know
what we needed yeah cuz good honestly if
we had have say voiceover for much of
our videos you don't need as good in the
moment audio if a lot of its voiceover
or if you're at a desk or invested in
like a crazy recording booth yeah and
then that would have been not used this
is the recording booth we just need a
staple a whole bunch of sound absorbing
panels to the ceiling and then we're
good to go yeah part of the room
makeover for this room I feel like we
don't actually there's so much sound F&E
dampening with like the green screen and
the art on the wall I think a lot of us
in the microphone to the microphone has
some sound dampening in it it's because
we're using like like podcasting
microphones instead of like lav
microphones laughs microphones I think
would pick up a lot more echo but it's
because these microphones are fancy yes
we do we do want to make over this room
that's complete side tangents but
anyways anyway so that's kind of like
phase one of editing very safe very
planned phase two was what was the
impetus for Phase two
I think the impetus was for free
- so let me say what face to use was
okay and then so phase two was starting
to incorporate more in the moment audio
and like talking to the camera more like
in an unplanned way not just intros and
outros that we wrote out and I think I
think the reason for it oh you know I
know what the reason kind of talked
about this wasn't when we started
filming collabs yeah well it was when we
did the UM collab with William Osmond
cuz nothing was planned and that showed
us that we could do it ya know we kind
of talked about this in the like we've
changed episode where we were talking
about the videos themselves but like the
editing for that is so different mm-hmm
this is something that we remembered and
take - that wasn't then take one take
two better take two for life take two
for life but so recording more real time
in the moment stuff and not planning
things basically what that meant is we
started rolling the camera the whole
time now from the outside the video
output probably didn't look that
different or that drastic because it
wasn't like we went from everything
voiceover - all of a sudden everything's
just like chaotic and in the moment and
I was talking to a camera and winging it
now when we started recording everything
we probably got a lot more in the moment
good things happening we did because I
was recording everything and we were
like on for the camera yeah all tasks
but but what that ended up doing is when
you record all of the footage in post
you have to decide what that is do you
use what your the audio that you're
saying to explain things or do you just
show what you did and do a voice over or
do you time-lapse through it like you
have to do you like quick jump cuts
yeah like repeated tasks yeah so you
have to make all of those decisions in
post because
having the choice of everything is
sometimes worse than just having it pre
decided in the moment 100% we'll get to
that later though okay okay or we'll get
to the pre decided part later mmm
but yeah so so every single video this
was our most footage heavy phase in
terms of the Edit and we would just have
hours hours of footage to go through and
I remember like we'd sometimes hear
other people unlike podcast or in their
videos talk about like oh man I had
three hours of footage to edit and it
was it was just terrible and I'm like
hahaha
because we would have so much remember
when we did our collab with Johnny Brook
crafted workshop oh yeah oh my god I was
shocked we were we all shook you know at
the end of the project we were both like
looking through our footage seeing if
there's like any clips we needed to give
to him or he needs to give to us and he
you know I pulled up like our folder of
footage and it was like dozens and
dozens of files individual video clips
and he pulled up his and I was like oh
oh my gosh did you lose footage and he
was like no it's everything it was like
twelve you know when he when Johnny sat
on his tool for the first time he didn't
even film it well it's a different type
of video never have a video by goes
talking to us to see like a different
process reaction you got so like yeah
you could capture that but like you
don't have to because everyone films
their videos differently and there are
reasons that that is different but I
think during this collaboration phase
that's part of the thing that fueled
this phase two of editing where we just
like over filmed insanely and that's
because during collaborations you know
it when it's just us two it's a lot
easier to be like mmm that wasn't great
can we redo that or like oh I didn't
really understand the way you're
explaining that can you can you say it
again or like anything we need to say
but also we weren't confident in what we
needed because when we script it all out
different oh yeah true
this specific issue that has to do with
co.labs is like when you're working with
other people you you can't plan what
they're gonna do and you don't always
feel comfortable like asking someone to
do something a second time or whatever
it is you know like like it was like
run-and-gun
the whole time for every collab why and
we need to like while we're there we
need to know that we've got everything
that we need which is why we when we're
editing but also it's like I feel now I
might be overconfident right now but
like now that we have more experience
with filming I feel like we could do a
collab and would film a lot less because
yeah Caitlyn can edit in her mind now
but that's another face but like I think
that that was like one of the reasons
why we over filmed
also is because we were wanting to get
everything we couldn't go back and do
things but also we weren't confident in
what we were getting so we're like let's
just get everything just in case
yeah and when you have everything then
edit takes so much longer
yeah like I there's been so many times I
still do it every now and then for like
but only like four intros because
there's a lot of pressure on intros
being really good like capture attention
but there's just been so many times
during that like film literally
everything phase where I would have the
same like part of the project and I
would edit it five or six different ways
completely different ways and then I'd
have Ivan come in and I'm like what's
the best way I'd send so much time
editing all these different ways and of
course all but one of them we would nix
and so
editing just took forever yeah and also
since we were recording everything we
didn't know when we had too much and
then to know if we had too much Caitlyn
had to edit it all and then cut the fat
away which is really painful because
Caitlyn would spent hours and hours
putting together this footage and then
when we watched at all as a whole would
be like mmm that whole part is just too
slow we're gonna have to nix all of that
and like when we're filming it takes a
lot longer to film - yeah cuz with the
different ways we film like when were in
montage mode filming is super fast
because we're just getting clips that
are a few
here a few seconds there but when we're
filming in like real-time mode like
during a resin pour we're like fully on
like knowing that and it takes so much
more energy it takes more time we have
to explain things to the camera we're
not like we have to have more cameras
running at once or like often times when
we like you this is maybe a little bit
like too much behind the scenes but when
when it's run-and-gun and we're trying
to be as efficient as we can sometimes
we'll be out there for the scenes where
that we're talking together and then
let's say we need to make a whole bunch
of cuts and do this whole assembly and
everything
Kalyan will film the first three cuts
and then she'll take the footage and
start editing well I just continue
cutting yeah and that's how you go
efficiently but if we're filming
everything like it and then would end up
with so much more footage and then
basically what would sometimes happen is
would edit that altogether and be like
oh it's boring let's just cut cut have
three quick cuts and then that's it yeah
but I feel like that face we had to go
through it we had to go through and like
if you're looking at so so some of the
videos I want to like this is one thing
I didn't really do the first thing we
recorded this podcast but I want to like
give a few examples just to like show
context not that I expect you guys to
like go back and watch them or anything
but like if you can pull them up in your
module we're gonna be disappointed while
you pull that up I just need to say like
a little side tangent you clips so funny
you know how I'm recording here and I'm
also recording to the left look to the
left look at that recording suppose
suppose so one of our videos is down
please computer or you're going in the
trash no you okay okay so I would say
like a lot of the earlier videos are in
that phase one those are pretty easy to
tell because they're like a 90%
voiceover but some of the first ones
that ended up being more like us winging
it one would be are you
yes okay so a few of those and let me
know how you feel about this to the tea
light candle holders with the storage
built in the what the video we recorded
right before hurricane Harvey oh man
yeah but remember there's a lot more
like us winging it remember it was like
raining out right and we were alive oh
my god we gotta finish this before the
hurricane comes yeah and all this stuff
but I remember like winging that a lot
more um the propane cannon propane
cannon was lame cannon was a huge set
forward for us huge net forward because
that also involved like taking something
out into the field yeah
edit wise it those two projects were
very similar yeah you know cuz it was
just like recording a bunch of stuff the
DIY concrete ring holders that one you
just reported like continually while
we're out there
yeah so that's like a few around that
time where we were doing and like any of
our collab videos where we just recorded
so much and in the Edit when you cut it
down the end result ended up not being
like a polar opposite of our phase 1
editing and though we filmed it in a
polar opposite style because some of it
still did end up being like voiceover
and montage yeah and I was still like
I'd still have like you know background
music that played throughout most of the
entire thing yeah I think of all of the
phases that we're gonna talk about are
there three or four five for now we have
all four phases I think this was
probably the most difficult phase yes
phase one was like growing pains
learning but like it wasn't the worst
phase two is worse we over filmed that
it was super stressful for Kaitlin
because like she had to make all these
decisions and edit and also led to like
such long editing times I remember when
we did the collab with Bob Bob we love
you that was an amazing experience but
oh my gosh telecom was so stressed Galen
was like like the most stressed well
like because because because it was a
huge opportunity us we we we thought
very lucky we wanted to make a good
video and we essentially filmed so much
before
time that we like like looked at that it
after the first round of caitlin editing
it it was 45 minutes long or more yeah
can we posted the full thing to patreon
yeah like a full like 45 to 50 minute
thing yeah on patreon and we're like we
can't post those on our YouTube channel
especially since our videos at the time
and it was just I was making a love
there ping-pong net that's 50 minutes of
like what we thought we're like there's
good stuff yeah and then we had to cut
it down we had it cut like 15 minutes
out of that all of our previous video
and so that's like three videos the
whole thing think of all the work all
the work and the filming and edit all
that cut so but another thing about that
specific edit is like we had a very hard
deadline because we'd like agreed upon a
specific date you know we wanted to like
make it work with Bob's schedule and but
this video especially because like we
were in you know being someone else's
shop like the lighting is different so
like our settings weren't quite right
you know it was like a unique audio
situation cuz instead of just being the
two of us there's a third person who we
were trying to like get his audio to
work with our audio it was the first
time that we were trying something like
that I think we had like our two lav
mics and then a salsa by combining in
the camera it was really messy so like I
had to do so much color and audio
correcting too and then the video itself
being so long the file was so big it's
kept crashing my computer and so we we
pulled a few late nights but then the
night before the Edit was gonna go live
we pulled a literal all-nighter and like
by like 2:00 a.m. I was at the 90
percent mark yeah but that last 10% took
from 2:00 a.m. until we uploaded yeah
they kept crashing like crazy you know I
completely understand that we had to go
through that because we had to know like
if we film everything what we're gonna
keep and then like through that
experience we learned so much and the
thing that crystallized everything and
took us from phase 2 to phase 3 on
was when we went to the UK and filmed
some videos with Alec yeah and watching
him how he worked and how he prepped
things for his editor cuz cuz Alec for
the longest time for those of you guys
who may not know who we're talking about
Alec Steele amazing YouTube personality
and and most people probably know who
we're talking about when we just had Bob
Bob I like to make stuff we should
probably be like yes anything wrong
about this podcast assume that it was
much better on the first and anything
that's really good at this podcast this
this iteration we added that yeah
podcast - for life yes podcasting for
life so Alec steel he has a YouTube
channel where he does blacksmithing and
he started his channel a long time ago
and for the longest time he was in the
blacksmithing the filming and editing
and he was doing a video every day so he
had to be very efficient very efficient
so when he brought an editor on he had
learned so much about how he filmed and
all of that and basically how he films
is when he filmed something he is doomed
edit in his head and even like what
he'll do is if he films a clip that
wasn't good
he'll delete it to not cause confusion
and then he'll redo it kind of so it's
like if he is filming a talking thing
he'll film the talking thing if he's
filming a montage he'll put it in
time-lapse mode and film the time-lapse
if he wants to do a montage mode then he
like um will just do a whole bunch of
short clips and then when it's dragged
into the timeline all at once the Edit
is like 50% done mm-hmm yeah which is so
cool cuz like when we would do a
time-lapse it would just be I was
recording the whole time and then an
edit I have to decide should i
fast-forward this yeah but then it's
like well first I have to listen to the
whole hour-long of footage to see like
if there's any good stuff and then I
just make the decision to fast forward
it to ten-second yeah we couldn't have
made the jump to phase 3 right at the
beginning though I don't think so though
because like like you said we had to
learn what types of clips were worth
recording and real like quote unquote
real time what types of clips could just
be montage through
yeah after our
I'm trying not to make this like a
repeat of our we've changed episodes I'm
trying to focus on like specifically so
from the outside phase two and phase
three probably don't look that different
in the videos and because like the end
result is very similar but you just drop
my hair time like this is like the thing
that we fiddle with like like Caitlyn
had this hair tie and both of us like
it's like coiled it looks like old phone
cord it's just a nice Idol thing to play
with
this is that if you're only listening
you're missing out on this this riveting
I forgot what I was saying anyways the
this is when like this is probably the
fastest editing or one of the fastest
editing phases for me oh yeah because
like we would choose in the moment
exactly what every scene was gonna be
and I think one reason that we had a
hard time doing it before is because we
would I wouldn't start editing until
everything was done the entire project
was completed but one thing I started
doing in the in phase 3 was editing as
we went and that made it a lot easier to
make those decisions as we go because
you know we'd film for half a day I'd
edit for half a day and I'd know like oh
there's been a lot of real-time I think
we need to jump into montage mode to
speed this up now I think the downside
of this editing is that like we weren't
we didn't really have any real-time
footage like one time footage we
wouldn't ever just let the camera roll
we went too hard too hard we went too
far in the extreme and again you
probably can't really tell from the
outside but like we knew so instead of
just letting it roll in seeing what
happened we would decide when we wanted
to talk to the camera and it wouldn't
just be voice over and we'd like be like
oh I'm gonna say something funny here
also then we weren't
you know through through most of these
phases we weren't the best at at any of
what we were doing I mean like if you
guys could see the raw footage of us
like in phase 2 especially when we're
filming everything like since we were on
we'd like try to say something funny or
try to do something funny or like things
like that
it has didn't land that this weren't
good there's nothing that will make you
feel less funny than watching an
hour-long footage of you and your spouse
trying to make joke I think we've got a
lot better about like knowing what
what's worth saying and what oh my gosh
oh my gosh thank goodness but but but oh
my gosh so we've been recording on the
computer in front of us and then the
video in front of us stopped but we have
the backup video going it stopped
earlier I know but and now it's good
again so we're gonna mix we're gonna
have to mix all of this hopefully the
audio track is good you know if there's
a part of the video of this podcast
where we're just frozen it's just gonna
be what it's good it's gonna be what its
gonna be
speaking of editing tricks yeah but
anyways isn't working now again you know
it's like why why like we were getting
the right things we're doing the right
thing isn't ooh sometimes that is don't
work and that bothers me yeah you know
anyways you into this hopefully it'll
just seem like nothing's going on so but
yeah so I think I think phase 3 is was
kind of like a briefer phase but it and
some examples of say few examples that
were in phase 3 it's so funny because I
like I know exactly what the videos
where I don't even have to I don't know
why I'm scrolling I don't have to look
it up so the
like thermoformed Corian salad servers
where we been more e'en into shape the
custom knife box the 3d print and
concrete candle holders oh yeah I
remember at the end of some of those
edits you were kind of not the most
satisfied yeah and I think it's I mean
looking back I generally liked them
but yeah there was definitely like in
some ways it felt like we were
especially because I had we had
experienced the record everything and
you get like really natural interactions
and then going through this thing that
was like slightly more planned out even
though it was like a thousand times more
efficient it felt like we lost a little
bit of the life in it um we were still
uh I will say during this phase we we
hey I'm still using music - still using
music in the same way like for the
montages but we did have more periods I
think where the music was just like
background - like because there was more
talking yeah parts so that made editing
the music a little bit easier and I
started utilizing multiple songs
thousand phase three
it started in phase three where it was
like three songs for a video yeah you
know like three different phases in
phase four goes up to 20 phase four I
went up to 23 okay so phase phase four
which is what I consider us to currently
be in is when we took the pre-planning
of deciding what was gonna be time lapse
what was gonna be montage what we didn't
need to spend much time on and we kept
that aspect of the planning and editing
but then for the real time like winging
it footage that percent that became like
a higher percent of our videos again but
it's unlike phase two where we just
filmed the entire thing and that way I
feel like we at this point had gotten
better at knowing what scenes would have
more good stuff just naturally come up
like
resin pours often do because like
something's gonna go wrong or if there's
like a more complicated glue up where
we're gonna need all hands on deck
yeah something you know things or even
like the very beginning of the glue up
and then like will shift in the or like
I will start a process in real time and
then once we know we've had enough good
things then we'll shift a montage or or
time-lapse and stuff like that that's
very true
or it'll be like real time for the
explanation part of it so like in the in
the most recent video the grass wall
video when we're talking about the like
stapling the grass we were recording in
real time in the beginning I'm so glad
we caught that like in real time yeah
but then like by the time we were
finishing the stapling it's like you
don't need to keep saying more stuff and
like once we have a process down that's
when we'll often switch into montage
mode because we're like okay now we just
like repeat this yeah anytime something
can go wrong or we'll have a reaction or
like various other like ways yeah then
we know to record it and like that more
real time mode and so yeah I think so
too going backwards phase one was script
and kind of plan everything and if we
happen to catch them in the moment thing
bonus phase two was film everything Gary
and efficient phase three how do you
summarize it phase 3 was the edit in
your in your head as you plan everything
I think phase four like like phase three
was like us hitting our stride of how we
want to do it but and then phase four
was taking everything to the next level
I think phase 4 was combining the best
of phase 2 and the best of phase 3 oh oh
yeah yeah yeah cuz phase 3 was too
strict on like like recording not enough
yeah and phase 4 but also I think the
one big thing about phase 4 and I'm not
sure where it fits into this but like we
started going a lot extra with effects
with zoom in with cups Kaelyn had a
whole bunch of music she added sound
effects she added all sorts of things I
think in phase 4 is when
like because and I'll use the music as
an example in all the other phases the
purpose of the music in the videos is to
be like cool chill beats to listen to
while you're watching those videos very
like you know Casey Neistat style vlog
beats and stuff and it was like like the
cutting of the footage to the beats and
getting like satisfying shots that
matched with the music was a really big
part of the edit and the video as a
whole yeah exactly and as we
transitioned and started including more
and more real-time stuff and especially
once we were in phase 4 which is where
we are now now the music is I don't
really use it for cool beats like at all
it's very rare every now and then I will
montage we have a long enough montage
and it's like a really cool scene like I
did in the whole no not on the props at
all
that's like complete opposite but like
in the blackhole table yeah I'm talking
like recent videos okay in the blackhole
table I like pulled in some cool music
when we were doing like very satisfying
pours and stuff but 99% of the music we
use these days is not to be cool it's
like to reflect the mood that I want to
come across in the edit
so it's either suspenseful or it's like
super derpy sounding or it's just like
background elevator type music it's more
for the purpose of conveying a specific
mood and it's more background these days
if that makes sense yeah so the prop off
was one of the first ones where I did
that because I was very inspired prop
off is where like it was a collab and we
did like a prop making competition and I
was inspired by the try guys without a
recipe yes which was inspired by the
Great British Bake Off but all the music
was to set a mood and that's that's one
of the first times where like the entire
video was edited in that way yeah
because it wasn't about being cool is
about like interactions and yeah like
building suspense and montaging
like cool 80 style montage yeah those
that was a really fun thing to film in a
way it was horrible for you to add it
because it was just so much footage so
much new new things all at once it was
like too much take on any new variables
which is why we've never done a video
like and I think so yeah the music was a
big difference in phase four one of the
biggest differences also is just like
not cutting out as much because like
phase three we would film everything and
cut so much of it in phase four I cut a
lot less and part of it's because we're
we're filming yeah
is everything okay I see you looking at
the equipment again I just fill my drink
it's okay it's just like I'm just
soaking like concerned about like
various things cause like the first
thing went wrong because there's like 13
minutes and 54 seconds we've been but
we've been over here we've been
recording for 52 minutes you know it's
funny but it's gonna be fine it's fine
it's fine let's not spill any more
drinks I'm gonna paper now you carry the
podcast we're wrapping up what phase 4
was no I wasn't oh wait I know I know
what I was talking about okay so another
thing is in in phase 4
like where whereas in phase 2 where we
recorded everything I cut so much stuff
and in phase 4 I decided to purposely
keep in a lot of things that in the past
we would have cut so like us doing a
take and then saying oh that take was
bad let's do it again I would leave in
us saying that take was bad let's do it
again and then just not use the second
take because I thought it was funny to
leave the bad take and not do the new
take or literally hot is it turn the fan
blowing air
but yeah so I remember the first video
where we did that very consciously and
like left in things that normally we
would have cut was Murphy bed part 2
yeah that's kind of the period where
this phase end of 20 19 18 Wow October
2018 so we've been we've been just doing
this new style for a little over a year
now
um but I remember like that was also a
phase where we were working late a lot
so there's a lot of times we just get
like loopy no it's crazy
sorry no I'll do my crazy tangent later
this is crazy this podcast take 2 take 2
I might worry about take 2 is that it
was gonna be too short
like like since we had already like set
all these things we were just gonna blow
through like oh there's four things we
went through one two three four boom Bom
Bom Bom Bom Bom and like the Russians
gonna be longer how do we do that we
would that was a phase where we were
working late a lot like much later than
we do now now these days like we try not
to be in the shop after like 8:00 or so
like will still work into the evenings I
mean the past couple of weeks we've been
trying to stop working all together by
like 8:30 to 9:30 which we use do not do
we would work into like 11:00 but we
used to be in the shop until like 11:00
or midnight or 1:00 and that's not very
smart because we were using power tools
but anyways I remember with the Murphy
bed like setting up I don't know we were
setting up for like the electric Colts
like extending the wiring to do the
built-in lamps and like we were just so
loopy and I just remember like I
remember me like crawling like balance
beaming across the bed frame because
there's no room and to get around and
like you like pitching Evan and
Caitlin's Airbnb and like all this stuff
that like normally I would have cut
casual and goofy not not short enough
for a funny little punch punch of like
in the moment which before I would have
been really self-conscious about putting
in because we were so worried about like
the video getting too long or worried
about just like if we included that
stuff people thinking like oh these guys
think they're really funny
like wasting my time but also I think
that is something that you can do when
you're a little bigger like I think you
have to have like you have to build up
the audience expectation I mean at least
I felt like we had to build up the
audience expectation that like there are
gonna be these parts and yeah is that
our that don't have to do with the
project and it's just like yeah goofy
stuff I mean if you started out as an
entertainment channel being entertaining
is expected and and that's not natural
but we started out as a DIY so Channel
and if so it used to be self conscious
about like occluding that wasn't like
the only part of our identity we've
slowly shifted that I didn't have
anything to do with the project yeah or
like the DIY so but at that point I was
just like you know what
I just wanna we're just gonna do it yeah
and so videos around that time at the
beginning of that were like Murphy bed
part to it which is funny cause Murphy
bed part one was not part of it yeah
started and then like the like laundry
room makeover and the geode table those
were kind of in that transition from
three to four and I think another thing
that that we started doing or that
started a couple months after that was
we started the gaming channel and we got
the gaming editors and even though like
you know when we first hired on the
editors we kind of gave them some
general guidelines and like how how we
like to edit and examples and stuff like
that they've kind of developed their own
styles and I've picked up things from
them that I do now in our main channel
videos yeah and I think that also one
thing that we did is we put together a
list of things that we do on our channel
and things that would work for the
gaming channel to add elements of humor
dad
like consistency between all of our
channels and all of that and having to
define that I think really helped us
reevaluate our content too and focus on
like focus in on what what we could do
to make our videos more fun and to take
them to the next level and stuff like
that so like through teaching it to
someone else and having to define it
ourselves
that helped clarify it for us also yeah
it was an interesting like side benefit
yeah and I think editing wise because
because we were including so much more
just like cameras on the tripod and
we're both doing a thing together type
footage we like I had to get more
creative with making that like breaking
it up a little bit so I started
incorporating a lot of like cut-ins and
like dramatic zooms on Evans face when
he makes an expression or like one thing
we picked up from the gaming editors is
like zooming in on our hands when we're
gesturing wildly especially when Evan
gestures wildly because Evan I'm like I
don't know why that's so funny
I just did it to you I put my hand on
your shoulder that's like just now I
realize like the gaming editor is often
like well cut into my mic dramatically
graphic your shoulders but I don't know
things like that are just funny to us at
least and so I've started incorporating
some of those things into the main
channel edits as well and then another
thing picked up from the gaming editors
is like adding occasional like memes or
like really bad Photoshop or like photo
shops are like bad like animate like
animated effects it's so interesting cuz
because doing that type of effect on
YouTube is like we love it like humor
like when other content creators do that
I just laugh so much it's so good but
like if anyone ever did that on TV or
movies it is it wouldn't fly this
doesn't make any sense I love what has a
stock photo as the watermark
we've done that do or like when it's
just like a really bad explosion effects
yeah like really bad green screen
overlays and like it's just funny they
add like that wouldn't fly on TV or
anything else really it's just yeah it's
interesting so anything else about the
four stages that we need to recover
anything we mentioned that was really
really good in the first take that we
need to bring up again the second no I
think that pretty much covers it yeah
yeah I will say overall I feel like I
have gotten a lot faster at editing and
I think like well this is one thing you
brought up I think I think if like a few
videos into the channel we had shown
ourselves what our videos look like now
we would be very intimidated BB's
variant by the length by the amount of
things that were doing by how much how
much of everything that we we've been
doing like if you looked at the Edit it
was like one row of video occasionally
maybe some text and then two rows of one
to two rows of audio depending on where
we were talking or if it was only the
music last time I had a pretty good
sports analogy something to do that
again because remember okay cool so it's
probably true for almost any sport but
when my analogy I'll do swimming because
I swam through high school and in the
very beginning of college when you first
start swimming and I taught swimming
lessons too but when you first start
teaching people how to swim to like get
to a competitive level you start with
some very basic things you start with
like the kick and all you focus on is
the kick then all you focus on are those
your arms and all you focus on is this
that or whatever and I think when we
first were starting youtube videos we
would do that we would focus on one
aspect and then like once we got that
kind of locked in without another thing
that would add another thing and we've
been adding all these things we've been
adding all these skills we've been
layering so that where we're at now you
do so much in moments like without
thought
that when we first started doing this
you would have like had such trouble
with I know that you've watched like so
many tutorials on editing and you've
watched like even a lot of research and
now you just go and you just do your
thing whereas in the beginning it was so
many unknowns I also say edits I used to
they used to take a lot more rounds yeah
you know like and not so much for the
very first style because like that it
was so planned to a tee but for fans
there's no other way to do it yeah
there's no other way to do it but in
phases 2 & 3
like the edits would go through so many
rounds like almost always at least 3
almost always like the rough cut and
then the refinement and then the final
refinement and then color an audio yeah
and I've gotten it down to like I'll do
one round and that'll get it to like 95%
and then the second round is just that
last 5% of like little tweaks here and
there but I'm a lot more confident in it
these days and part of that's pretty
recent honestly like I feel like I used
to have a lot more phases of this
happens more like the longer chunk of
continual editing we have to do the more
I have this feeling but I used to like
I'd get through a chunk of editing and
I'd be I'd say to Evan I'm like I don't
know it's good I feel like I'm so like
bored by this let's just watch it and
see it then I'll watch it like that's
pretty good yeah and I feel like I have
a lot more confidence now to know that
it will be good and yeah that's myself
and I'll get so down about it and know
that I would like get that down about it
and it would this one mostly happened
with videos where like there did have to
be longer chunks of continual footage
like the Bob Ross that was filmed all in
one go oh those are the hardest free
that it's still those the hardest are
like the UM our first 37 attempts at
soap making that was all in one go yeah
and those are even though they're easier
to film because there's so much harder
to edit but but any long chunk even like
doing like the longer resin pores that
might have just been like part of the
video not as much footage is like your
eyebrow so this
those were still a lot harder and I feel
like I've gotten better yeah so I think
the thing that's interesting to me
looking back is there are four distinct
stages but the fourth stage is the most
interesting to me Stage one scripted
filming less stage to the camera again
this is such a hot mess oh I need to go
back and let me to fix everything camera
stopped recording it's all fixed so
stage two we filmed too much Stage three
we filmed too little stage four is kind
of the happy balance between filming too
much filming too little but also Stage
four is when we change a ton of stuff
stylistically in that it yeah so it's
like Stage four was two things changing
a lot stage at the same time Stage four
is when we finally just embraced like
this doesn't have to be a tutorial
before we were trying to make it make
the videos like entertaining tutorials
and now by Stage four we were like it
doesn't like the tutorial part doesn't
have to be the primary purpose yeah we
kind of like let go of that and that
changed how we edited stuff it's very
interesting yeah okay
let's move on to thing of the week
mine is a game - video it's a YouTube
video from Raz Boonton and it's gaming
for a non gamer and it was a very
interesting video in which the content
creator who has the channel he does a
lot of video game related stuff and he
thought it'd be interesting and to kind
of put his wife through an informal
experiment where she plays video games
for the first time without much help for
him and he without much experience
gaming yeah and and she sees kind of
through her eyes and through her
experiences what video games are like
for people who don't play video games
and there's a ton of interesting
conclusions we're like kind of talking
about the building blocks if you start
playing a game that's release now and
you haven't played any games in the past
any simpler games or something
then the number of thing is that the
game assumes that you know is a lot and
and it's just so it was awesome that's a
very interesting video and I think that
whether you play games or if you have
never played games in your life it's
very interesting because it's like the
the meeting of those two in a way yeah
and it's all about like the psychology
yeah and like the it was like a little
mini social experiment kind of just on
his wife but it was it was very
interesting and like personally I could
kind of relate to both sides because
there's some like types of games and
they they did a like wide array of game
types there's some types of games that
I'm very familiar with and very
comfortable doing and then some like
first-person shooters for example that I
just am not good at I've never been good
at and things aren't intuitive so I
could like relate to both sides of it
like the totally feeling lost and
overwhelmed in the game types that
you're not familiar with and then just
like how so much you don't even think
about yeah there's also just like a very
generally like positive and wholesome
video at the same time I like home we
like wholesome stuff
alright Kailyn what do you have for us
today
the week is the latest William Osmond
egg-drop video featuring howtobasic
it was so good and we've watched most of
the egg drops I think and this is my
favorite just cuz like okay I don't know
if you guys probably have heard of
howtobasic but if not like it's just
it's very chaotic
he doesn't talk it's a lot of egg
smashing and like sighs laughing this is
strange
it's very strange very bizarre and it
was so interesting seeing these two
styles come together and you're just
like what is he gonna do anyways it was
a very entertaining video and as always
we will have links to the videos and the
thing of the week section in our show
notes / video description huzzah
I feel like we should say that more
often but we always have our thing of
the week and sometimes we speak about it
kind of generically like I got these LED
candles I really like and then like that
gives people nothing yeah you know but
like we always have likes everything is
always in the description and that
brings us to the end of the podcast
thank you guys so much for sticking with
us through this I think I don't think
we're gonna cut any of it out let's not
cut any of it out because there's
there's gonna be enough editing so like
welcome to the chaos
welcome to the chaos thank you for
staying this whole time and staying till
the end
we really appreciate you guys and we
really appreciate everyone who supports
us by watching by sharing by rating by
reviewing it makes it makes us like when
when the podcast have failed the first
time I consider just like let's just not
do it
but we don't want to disappoint you guys
we don't disappoint you who's listening
right now yes I'm talking specifically
to you hi yes hello
thank you for for supporting us and yeah
yeah I think it's really cool when I'm
like on our it'll be like on a main
Channel video or something and someone
will ask like oh how did you guys meet
and someone replies with a link to the
podcast episode where we met
so like thank you guys for sharing it
that's really cool yeah and then we'll
look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]